have you
thought about killing yourself
i have not
i have not have you seen that thought in
the distance
i am fortunate that that has not
come to my mind and i have not seen it
even in the distance and i in in in some
ways i've i've wondered if that's made
me
am i a less
you know effective psychiatrist because
of that i've been
i've i've felt everything stripped away
i've been at the lowest of the low
and yet the
that there's still hope there's a light
of hope still at the end of the day
right
so you've never lost even for brief
moments that um
no reason to feel hope at that moment
honestly
uh
[Music]
so it was just the light without reason
yeah that's right
what wisdom do you draw from that time
about
so first of all
you said something funny which is i
wonder if it
that it's somehow
not having thoughts of suicide
limits your capacity to truly understand
somebody who is
having those thoughts
so how many demons must a psychiatrist
have
in order to be a good psychiatrist yeah
you know this is a really interesting
question i think everybody knows and i
can say this that psychiatrists
can be a little unusual there we uh
we're
we think about ourselves right we think
about our brains that may be one reason
why we become psychiatrists is we think
oh that's interesting going on in there
what's that about so a little little
introspective a little introverted maybe
and that's what can make us good
when we're good
and
but also that
that may select for people who have some
unusual aspects but you don't have to
have all of them
there's a lot that can can go wrong in
the in the psychiatric realm
i think having
some of those some of it but not all of
it is enough you get to see
how low things can can get you can get a
you get empathy from that even if the
symptoms are not the same um just
empathy
for struggle for suffering that's right
that's right
do you yourself have to practice
observing triggers
just as a human operating in this world
i've definitely those those skills that
have come from
from therapy i've i've found i found
them useful yeah i if i noticed that uh
we we've all been through experiences
where we wonder oh i got really mad in
that interaction
why did i get that mad you know yeah
sure maybe i could have been irritated
but man why did i yeah and and and then
thinking about it and realizing okay
you know
back up here think about the broader
context um
uh think about
what how that relates to you know prior
events in my life okay yeah so this is a
thing for me uh when something of this
class happens
then it triggers me
so going forward i'm going to be aware
of that
um
and i've definitely used that because
it's
you don't you don't want to be out of
control those emotions you want to
identify them you want to know where
they come from and
you want to head them off as a
as a civilized human being living on
this earth trying to get along with
other people you want to understand
those moments let me um
return to robin williams for a second
and looking at robin williams the
the actor the oh sorry the human
and because you mentioned um
for depression you can have everything
going well
and i think there's just
uh
famous cases of just public figures
because a lot of people know them
where
they they suffer quietly
and it seems like from the outside
perspective that they
have everything going for them that
they're top of their career you know two
people that come to mind are
robin williams and anthony bourdain
what insight do you have and why
either of those taken why robin williams
a comedian one of sort of the most jolly
humans obviously there was always the
darkness that he was channeling
channeling in order to
present the happiness but it feels like
that realness is only possible when
you're deeply self-honest and analytical
and
and then then if you're deeply
self-honest you're going to realize that
there's a lot of beautiful things about
life that you can discover and if you do
that how can you possibly then take your
own life and you go through all these
thoughts
and
i think a lot of a lot a lot of people
really loved robin williams which is why
it was really difficult to see how can
even
him how can even robin williams take his
own life so i don't know if there's
something to be said about the nature of
depression from just looking at his case
i think
the action of suicide is not well
understood
it doesn't always although often is
correlated with depression there are
cases of suicide where there is not
clear depression that that's in the
minority by the way if i just look
because you said it's so interesting
action of suicide because there's also
thoughts of suicide right and probably
those that probably
somewhat understood but it's an
interesting
because you can think of suicide
if you have suicidal ideation you can
think of that for so many reasons
that's right and
and the
i mean i
thoughts
sometimes like painful thoughts
angry thoughts or thoughts in general
can be very different like fantasies for
example you can fantasize
like sexual fantasies you can um
fantasize i was just the humor's sake
wanted to mention stuff but then people
think i'm serious i'm not going to
mention anything but uh sexual fantasies
and then there's i know there's people
that have sexual fantasies and they
don't want to actually do that in real
life that that sexual fantasy serves
some kind of purpose in imagination only
and in that same way suicide might serve
a purpose and imagination only is very
unlikely to lead to action and yet
there's other
thoughts that maybe are more amorphous
that do lead to action and that leap
uh yeah that oh boy that's a facet and
that's such a philosophically powerful
thought
to not exist
like that question that's this uh is its
archer or kamu
kamu well the mythicist
who says
like basic question of why live
good question yeah
right
so
that's a great question actually and
there are other related questions some
people
may have the thought of suicide
uh
because
there seems no point there's no joy in
life that's one reason that some people
can put forward
sometimes there's an it's not just the
absence of of joy there's an active pain
an active psychic pain in some people
and that the inescapability of that
is enough to drive the thoughts of
suicide
and then there are interpersonal and
cultural reasons as well that can show
up
the but the act this act of ending of
the self is in all these cases there's
no real way to study this in animals no
other animal as far as we know that we
can study
has this concept of this is myself
the situation is not
tolerable therefore i will end the self
to our knowledge this is not something
that that can be studied in other
animals so remains this this uh
uh
very poorly understood uh action and
in predicting it so what do we do with
psychiatrists we have this challenge
people come to the emergency room
they say they're suicidal or their
friends say they're suicidal or they've
taken some action
that that didn't lead to death
what do we do well there's a whole range
of options you know was it a suicidal
gesture in the sense of not intending
death uh or was it uh was the intent uh
death
and if it was the intent was was death
what were the reasons are the reasons
transient are they gone now
what's the probability that it'll be
repeated
so we do all these things just to decide
what sort of treatment should be carried
out but nowhere
is there a deep understanding of the
biology of the cells and circuits and
activity patterns that underlie the end
the action to end the self
it's a very
it's so it's this frustrating thing it's
it's so
timely it's so common it shows up in
veterans it shows up in kids it shows up
in people at every stage of life
and yet we're very bad at understanding
it and we're relatively poor at
predicting it and our tools are are not
very
powerful we can put people in a locked
unit we can give them care therapy for a
while at some point
we release them and there's only so much
we can do it's one of the most
frustrating things and the suffering
that is linked to suicidality but it is
a decision and it is an action
and if you look at optogenetics you
should be able to
one day sort of understand the dynamics
of such
weighty decisions
the individual causes then if someone is
anhedonic if there is no joy in life
that
very likely is addressable by
optogenetics we know how to
turn that dial very robustly in animals
the
motivation to overcome challenges that
we have some some hope of understanding
psychic pain internal negative states we
have actually a handle on that as well
there's a structure in the brain called
the habenula
and some linked structures around it
that seems to generate this negative
internal state that's it's active when
a state of acute disappointment acute
outcomes that go wrong
not as expected um
uh you know
moments of unexpected pain the habenula
is there it seems it's active
to report on internal
negativity with its set with its action
and so you could imagine strategies to
target this brain structure that
might have the effect of reducing
psychic pain reducing the negativity of
internal states that is a very concrete
hope it's precise it's anatomical
optogenetics has given us all the firm
foundation we need
to go
after that question so i think there is
hope uh if you look at the individual
causes the individual symptoms relating
to suicide
and then it's like a puzzle you put
together the puzzle pieces well by the
way i do think my
uh habenula
is uh
very functioning very actively
and i wonder if it's like because
because you you can also learn to
channel these things right some some of
the things we suffer from
i mean there's degrees of suffering can
be
um a source of
progress and personal growth and
development and all those kinds of
things and i mean i
um
what is it nietzsche suffered from
stomach
issues
you know
i wonder if he'd written some of those
things if
if his stomach was all great
right i mean there's i kind of think
that
uh a difficult life in some form you can
get you get to choose in some regard and
some of you don't the difficulties you
have and the ones you do have it's nice
to use if possible it's sometimes it's
nice to treat sometimes it's nice to
it's nice to use well the way you phrase
it i think you're using it i could be
wrong
but if you you phrased in this
semi-humorous way about your herbanulla
it seems to me that you're you're using
that uh to good effect now
but one never really knows what someone
else's internal state is as i look at
you i don't know the depths of what's
going on
and it's possible uh that that it's it's
it's a much harder situation in there um
yes
so that's i actually worry about this a
lot so i'm extremely self-critical like
in the privacy of my own mind which is
an interesting thing when you get to
meet the internet and the internet will
tell you you suck
uh
but
first for now now this is what i worry
about i'm very paying attention for now
it's really i just have this like very
negative voice
but that voice seems to be very useful
for productivity yes and so i channel it
i just put on the table and let that
voice like talk to me but i'm very i'm
like
monitoring that voice because looking at
robin williams you know you get older
your brain changes or like your and and
then that voice can now all of a sudden
grow
right and then where you can't control
as much just be very careful with these
kinds of things you're very right about
that i so my my negativity i have this
uh i never think i've done enough is
sort of where my my negativity comes
from inside i i i never think
that i've
i've
met the potential of the moment i
haven't done
i haven't you know
made the most of the opportunities that
are available
still early i haven't you know you know
progressed as far as i should and
exactly as you're saying
that works for a while
but then what happens as you get later
in life and there's less
runway
to
you know fix that and then maybe maybe
then maybe then that negative voice is
is a problem but also at that point the
negative voice starts having more and
more of a point that's when when you're
being when you're being very successful
it's easy to be like no okay well
like later in life you're really
literally just sitting there on a
on a rocking chair doing nothing and
then
it's
or maybe any kind of tragedy happens
loss of a loved one
loss of a job
loss or you get screwed over in some
kind of um some kind of way i don't know
those and then also in the negative
voice it's just you and the negative
voice for
days and days and days and so i don't
know
to go back to your example of robin
williams i don't know what was going on
inside him i don't know the nature of
his internal state was it a was it
active psychic pain that
man mentioned may i interrupted just say
that sergey posted an examination of
robin williams's brain tissue suggested
that he suffered from quote diffuse
l-e-w-y lewy body dementia
lbd depression is a symptom of lbd and
it's not about psychology it's rooted in
urology this is words from
his brain was falling apart yeah lewy
body dementia this is a very interesting
neurological disorder where
uh among other things there are there's
neuron death indeed so you've got frank
neuron loss it's not just a matter of
some long-standing
psychic pain but you've got a
progressive
loss and so clearly you've got a
situation where he could have finally
reached a point where
the balance that he'd worked out between
negativity and positivity
was disrupted due to loss the wrong
cells died the wrong projections were
cut by the lewy body dementia
certainly dopamine neurons die in lewy
body dementia those are neurons that
give rise to
much of the feelings of reward and
pleasure that we experience
among other roles
so
clearly in his case there could have
been a very
concrete cellular neurological issue
that was progressive and pushed him to
that point
but what were you uh
were you about to make a point about
broader that if there isn't another
neurological degeneration yeah so in his
case not knowing that uh
it could have been simply that let's say
he had
an internal psychic pain state and it
was in
he was in sort of a compensated mode for
much of his life able to generate enough
joy from his his comedy and his social
interactions and
and then but eventually later in life
you know the
the those things drop away the balance
shifts you get tired of fighting the
pain for that long and then so you've
got this time dependent
non-stationarity that happens and then
the same
symptom becomes no longer tolerable in
the end
you